claude blanchemaison bonjour heureux de
vous retrouver dans la matinale de rtl
france alors est-ce que la désignation
d'un nouveau premier ministre à genève a
des chances d'aboutir
je crois que ce qui est remarquable
c'est que les 75 délégué libyen
venus de tous les horizons de tous bords
approuvée par l'onu sont réunis donc
pour la deuxième fois cette fois ci à
genève et qu'ils ont la semaine en
réalité pour choisir sur une liste de 45
candidats également approuvé par l'onu
un premier ministre ou l'avait dit ses
deux adjoints et puis trois membres du
conseil présidentiel qui fait donc
chargée d'assurer la transition sous la
forme d'un gouvernement unifié jusqu'aux
élections du 24 décembre prochain
élections législatives élection
présidentielle la difficulté c'est que
leur travail est un petit peu miné par
les principaux candidats à ces postes
puisqu'on sait que à tripoli du côté du
gouvernement d'union nationale le
ministre de l'intérieur brigue le poste
de premier ministre et que l'actuel
premier ministre démissionnaire n'est
pas tout à fait d'accord avec cette
candidature et la même manière
du côté du maréchal haftar il ya une
rivalité très forte entre le maréchal
haftar et le président du parlement de
tobrouk qui lui aussi est candidat à ce
poste de premier ministre
alors il aimera que ce processus qui
était en cours à genève va a duré qu il
peut durer d'ailleurs un peu plus
longtemps que cette semaine pour finir
par dégager un consensus
mais ce ne sera pas sur sa cible
alors claude pour que le gouvernement
fonctionne il faut qu'ils aient des
troupes on imagine alors est-ce qu'il
réussira à s'imposer
alors ça c'est l'une des grandes
difficultés c'est que à supposer que les
soixante quinze délégués réunis à genève
cette semaine ou un peu plus tard
réussissent à désigner ce premier
ministre ses deux adjoints plus les
trois personnes du conseil présidentiel
qui gère
la transition de quelques troupes
disposeront-ils on voit bien depuis hier
que les actions les différentes milices
qui sont autour de tripoli qui avait
essayé de s'unifier sont à nouveau
divisée entre les partisans du ministre
de l'intérieur qui voulait devenir
premier ministre
qui voudrait te dit décidée par cette
instance de genève et l'actuel premier
ministre démissionnaire qui avait été
approuvé par le nul qui lui même
probablement agite de façon souterraine
certaines des milices pour le soutenir
car après tout bien que malade il se
verrait bien reconduit dans ce poste de
premier ministre
donc de quel trouble de quels moyens là
les personnalités qui seraient des
vignes est un jeune aire disposerait
pelle pour assurer la paie actuellement
le cessez le feu qui a été décidé à la
fin du mois d'octobre est respecté et
d'ailleurs une commission mixte
militaire qui fait respecter le cessez
le feu cessez le feu
c'est une bonne chose mais évidemment
pour imposer un gouvernement unifié
il faudrait probablement un petit peu
plus alors les acteurs étrangers en
libye et ali russie france ou encore en
turquie ont-ils intérêt à une
stabilisation de la libye
c'est la question clé il n'y aura pas de
stabilisation sans accord entre ces
grands parrains ces grands tuteur qui
les uns soutiennent sa rage le président
le premier ministre démissionnaire après
du gouvernement approuvé par l'onu et
ceux qui soutiennent qu'ils se tiennent
le maréchal haftar il vient évidemment
actuellement des troupes étrangères sur
le sol libyen
le nu il ya quelques semaines estimé
leur nombre à environ 20 milles et ce
qui fait quand même beaucoup
certaines sont des troupes qui
représente les états de la région
d'autres sont des mercenaires qui
peuvent représenter des étapes plus
lointains et on voit bien que les uns et
les autres consolident leurs positions
sur le terrain et probablement pas pour
ensuite se mettre à la disposition d'un
gouvernement unifié de transition qui
préparait enfin des élections du 24
décembre
donc il faut encore probablement à un
chemin dans ce processus de paix qui
amène les grands parrains que sont la
turquie l'egypte la russie mais aussi
sans doute les grands pays occidentaux à
se mettre ensemble pour décider enfin de
donner à la libye un gouvernement unifié
qui permette d'aboutir à la paix un bon
si c'est que la production pétrolière a
est reparti or évidemment la libye ces
bons coups le pétrole et on voit bien
qu'il ya un certain consensus entre les
différentes parties prenantes pour
remettre en service les installations
pétrolières et pour reprendre les
exportations de pétrole de la libye qui
après tout sans sa seule ressource aux
sources qui actuellement ensemble d'îles
permet aux différentes factions
d'acheter des armes puisque là encore
l'onu a déclaré au cours des derniers
mois elle avait pu constater environ 80
infraction à l'embargo sur les
livraisons d'armements et l'onu de façon
équanime en attribue la moitié
au gouvernement de tripoli et la moitié
au maréchal haftar merci beaucoup
claude pour votre expertise claude
blanche raison je le rappelle on vous
retrouve tous les mardis matin dans
l'édito de la matinale